このところでの二番目なんですけど
日本語のピンコードこの辺か？あのまあ 四十六 ページのあのところで
このまた比丘たちを正思惟とは何か
欲を離れた思惟 怒りのない思惟
害意のない思惟ですと
比丘たちよ これが正思惟と言われますというところ
カタマーチャ・ビッカリ・サンマー・サンカッポ
カタモーチャ・ビッカリ・サンマー・サンカッポ・ネッカンマ・サンカッポ・アッビャーパーナ・サンカッポ・アヴィーンサ・サンカッポ
アヤン・ウッチャティ・ビッカリ・サンマー・サンカッポ
というところ まあ一般的に言えば
この八正道っていうのは仏道であって
仏教の道 方法ですから
で 二番目はサンカッパ
ソーシーですね まあ一般的な言葉で言えば考えるっていうことなんですね
で 何を考えればいいんですかと
まあ正しく考えなさいと言ったってもね
これわかりませんだからね
どんな風に正しく考えるんですかと
それなんか  有働が別にね
まあ間違って考えるとかね
正しく考えるかっていうことはあんまり話にならないことで
ただまあなんとか考えてはいるんです
で 考えることはまあ論理的でない場合はまあ正しくないと言えますけど
まあいくらかな 論理的に考えてるでしょうと思いますけど
でも問題は まあじゃあ大体誰でもそれなりの論理で考えてますけど
その論理的に考えるためには
まあ適切に正しく情報なければいけません
それで我々はすべて情報を頭の中でまとめてますかと
揃ってますか？と言えばそれではないんですから
自分持っている情報で考えてるんですよ
ですから まあ正しいかないかと言えたところじゃないんです
で また他の情報がある可能性はいくらでもあります
何かにすぎて自分が完全に知ってるんだっていうことは
もう人間には一向に言えないことなんですね
これは私は完全に知ってますよと言って言うことは何もないんですね
どんなものについても
さらに知ることはできるでしょうし
どんなものについて 大体勉強する世界だからね
何か勉強して じゃあ終わりました
それで終わるわけじゃないんです
それをさらに知ることもできるんですね
ですから 例えば何か学問
何か専門的な何か知識得たとして
それについて考えている場合は
その考え方正しいかと言えば
これはわからないもんなんですね
で 言えるのは まあ知らない人よりは間違いに考え方は間違いですよというぐらい
別にその人がその項目について
自分知ってる世界について完全たる知識得ているかっていう
そんなことはないんだからね
で いくら知識得ても さらに知ることはできるし
さらに情報インプットすることもできるし
ですから まあ言えるのは
まあ他の人よりまあ間違いに考えるんだっていうぐらいのこと
ですから 世の中で生きてる人間っていうのは
まあ自分の考え方は正しいと思うんですけど
それは大きな誤りなんですね
大きな誤り で そこら辺気をつけなさいよということでもありますね
で まあ例えば弁護士がいるとする
まあ一応もうやっと試験受けたとする
免許を取ったとする  試験も国家試験も合格したところで
まあ一応弁護士の資格を取ったということなんですけど
だからまあある立場から言えば
まあまあ一人前になったなったでしょうと
でも それで彼がわざと間違ってる法律考えるわけじゃないんですよ
でも さらに研究した人々がまたいるんですね
もっと資格取ってる人々もいるし
日本のシステムはわかりませんだけど
まあまあ 他の国 国ではまあ弁護士の資格もいろんなランクがあるんですよ
いろいろランクがありまして
それにすごい研究して研究して
それからいろんな経験あって
そこを積み加えて次の試験受けなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の国でも もう普通の弁護士と違って
もう上上上上ランクいくつかあります
だから まあその一番上のランクになったら
まあなんかすごい偉い名前で呼ばれますけど
で それ以上勉強するとかそういうのはないんですけど
その人々の中ではもっと優秀な人がいたりして
抜群に能力ある人がいたりして
その人々はまた その中でまた上のまた仕事をもらったりする
そうやってこのいろいろありますからね
ですから 例えば最高のレベルにいる弁護士と比べて
今日もう国家試験合格した弁護士と比べると
今日国家試験受けて合格した弁護士から何か相談に乗ってみても
その人は真面目に答えてくれるんだけど
最高なレベルの弁護士の答えはもっとマチでしょう
だから言えるのは この人の考え方はもっとマチですよと
ですから 我々人間にいつでも自分の思考に対して言えるのは
他の人の思考と考えて
自分には情報がたくさんあるならば
経験もあるならば まあ自分の考え方はマチではないかと
こういうわけで こういう情報が自分が持ってるんだからと
で それしかできない 自分の考え方は完璧だということは絶対ありえないことで
できないことなんですね
ですから それなのに人間っていうのは常に自分考えることは正しいと思っちゃう
だからそこら辺についてもいくらかの理解が必要なんですね
自分が必死でも完全に真面目に考えることはそうかもしれませんだけど
だからといってそれは普遍的な世界に当てはめてみると正しいということは言えないんです
誰かの思考と比べたら
どちらがマチかと言えるだけであって
最小なところまでも比較的にんですよ
これよりこれがいいということであって
これ最高ということは言えないんですね
そこをわかってほしいんですね
我々の考え方について
自分が言ってることはこういうことだからこれですよと
で だから仏教的なになったっていうところは
そういうポイントはすごく大事なんですね
だから 本当の仏教徒の間では何もこのいさかいないというところが
このいさかいっていうのは思考のぶつかり合いなんですね
ほとんど 他の問題っていうのは
まあそれほど問題ではないんです
だから たとえ喧嘩したっても
どこかでこの思考の問題があって喧嘩するんですよ
だから 人間のもう和がないという
調和がないということ
お互いにうまくつなげて生活しないということは
この思考がまあぶつかり合うんですね
なぜ思考がぶつかるかというと
自分が真面目に考えているんだから正しいと思っていることなんですね
だから 仏教の智慧がある人が
やっぱり思考っていうのは完全になりくはないんだと
自分たちが持っている智慧が
自分持っている情報によるものなんですね
知識っていうのは で その中でも
例えば同じ情報を知っている二人もっていたっても
情報の処理能力 経験 いろんなこと関係あるんですね
ですから 死ぬまで知識っていうのは
まあ本当は増えるもんなんですよ
ですから 一つこの頭も良くなるし
死ぬ瞬間までもいろんなことを勉強した方が
また逆にいいんですよ
知ってるんだと これで十分やと思って止まるんじゃなくて
十分にはならないんです
これは欲と同じく いくらあっても満たせない状態なんですよ
知識も お金も同じでしょうに
いくらあっても じゃあこれで十分です
結構ですという風に欲ある人は思わないでしょうし
とにかく欲っていうのは
どんな欲でもこれで十分ということはならないでしょうし
で 知識も 知識も欲ですけど
ですからもういくらあっても足らんもので
ですから 知識が増えるっていうならば
やっぱり 死ぬ瞬間まで勉強しなくちゃいけない
それで頭の中でいろんな種類の知識がぶつかって頭狂ってしまう可能性もあります
それはありますよ いろんなことを勉強しちゃったらぶつかるんだから
思考 自分の頭の中で 試しに大乗仏教でも勉強してみてください
ぶつかると言うとね すっごく頭がおかしくなるんですよ
だからまるっきりこの一つの頭っていうのは
一つのシステムに自分の思考
あの体系化したいんですよ
だから我々は頭の中で勉強したものはある体系化しようと必死になって頑張るんでしょうね
で それでいろんなことを勉強しちゃうと
体系化できなくなっちゃうと
もうかなりトラブルなんです
世の中で他の人よりすごい頭がいいんだと言われる人々っていうのは
何勉強してもある体系が頭の中にありますよ
そういう生まれつきでもこの体系思想
体系というものがね できていると
どんなものでも勉強できるんですね
例えば昔いたアインシュタインのような人々っていうのは
もう何やっても上手できる
数学物理学だけじゃなくて
バイオリン弾いたっても上手と
文章書いたっても抜群に立派
文学者みたい あれ何なのかと
別にアインシュタイン文学者ではないんですけど
彼が書いた手紙とかすっごい立派でしょうね
それは小さい時から頭の中で体系化できているんですね
とにかくユダヤ人がなぜそんなに力強いかというと
この子供の時からもこの体系作ってるんです
ユダヤ文献文学読んでみてください
思考体系作ってるんですよ
思考そのものではなくて
すっごいもう驚くほどのしっかりした基本思考体系
小さい時からも教えてるんです
だからユダヤ人の間でやる子供たちに教える物語なんかは
思想体系作るんであって
ポケモンの物語 ドラえもんの物語とは全く正反対
こちらの子供たちがドラえもんを見たり
なんとかいろいろそうやって漫画なんか見たり
育てるでしょうし 思想体系その中にないんで
まるっきりない 何考えてるかその日で
その日でなんかもう何かやって何か終わるという
だからキャラクターだからいろいろキャラクターが作ったりして
ずっと同じキャラクターが同じことを毎回毎回もうやっているだけで
その中で思想体系っていうものはできていない
だからこのある思想体系ができちゃったら
もうその人は何勉強したっても
頭の中でそのシステムの中にきちんと置いておくことはできるんです
そうでない人々がいろんなことを勉強しちゃうと
もう大変なことにはなります
だから頭がいいか悪いかということは
このものを覚えられるかないかということじゃないんですよ
もう日本の教育ではちょっと間違いがありまして
たくさん覚えておけばいいやと
そうするともう世界に勝てるんだと
世界一になるんだと言って辞書を丸暗記する
でも英語を喋れない 体系ができてないんだからなんですよ
アジアでフィリピン人でしょうかね
まあもう何のことなく英語を喋ると
別にそんな勉強してないないんですよ
結局は 何かを体系できてきてるんだから
そういう風になってる
でも単なるこの あの 日本の歴史勉強する人って
ずーっともう死んだ連中の天皇連中名前なんかリストやらね
もう覚えといたって もう何の役にも立ちません
そんなことは 歴史の中でどんな出来事が起きたかとかね
それはいろいろ歌にしたり
いろんなことにしたりして丸暗記してるでしょうね
役に立ちません ですから
この そうではなくて この何かのストーリーなんですよ
頭の中で何かのストーリーがきちんと基本的なものができていないと
頭のいい人間になりません
それは今日に関係ない余計な話なんでかもしれませんだけど
まあついでに言っただけなんですけど
忘れてください で だからいろいろ
例えばあの本も読んだ
この本も読んだと言ったっても
頭よくならないんですよ
で やっぱり基本思想体系っていうものはね
できていないと それは小さい時もできちゃった方が一番便利なんですね
いつか作らなくてはならないんですね
そうでないと落ち着くということはできません
だからこのいろんなことを勉強するのは決して悪くないんです
勉強したっても 思考自体が
例えば天台の思想とパーリ仏教の思想が両方勉強したら
これ頭の中で全くはめなくて
ってぶつかっちゃうと何の役にも立ちません
何かの形でそれをはめてつなげて
この関係とかその体系作っておかないと
ただ いいえ これではこれとこれは違いますよと
いい加減に言ったっても
だから何ですか？と なんで両方知ってるんですか？と
それで役に立たなくなっちゃうんですね
まああの知識について
まあまあそれぐらいのことで
まあまあ満たすことはありませんということと
知識はたくさん知った方がいいということで
それでまあ死ぬまでも別に目的があるわけじゃなくて
まあ今日夜死ぬことになってあっても
今日の勉強はした方がいいっていうことになるんです
で それでそれは本人が自分で思想体系を作っている人であるならば
勉強すればするほどすごく立派な頭のいい人間になる
思想体系できてないと
途中で頭が狂って混乱して
まあまあ午後普通に何も勉強してしてない人と同じレベルになる
そこで仏教でいうのはそういうことだと
知識っていうのは今説明した通りやということを理解することなんですね
いわゆる仏教の体系から言えば完全じゃないでしょ？という答えでしょ
例えばある人がもう英語の文学
何て言いますか 英語 え
文学やったとする まあそれはもう世界一流のもう学者に出会っても
年 年 まあまあ年も研究するかもしれません
英語というか その他言語のもう生まれた以前文化も何て言いますか
この昔のこのcivilization文明
まあそこから単語の言語の変化
流れ 思想の流れからもう現代のところまで勉強したっても
言えるのはそれ完璧ですか？と
とは言えない 言えるのは
まあこれぐらい知ってるんだっていうことだけ
だから完璧ということは成り立たない
ですから 英文学を四年研究したっても
その人が私が絶対的に知ってるんだと私の思考が正しいと思ったら
そこに間違いですよ そこでぶつかり合いが生まれるんだと
ということなんですね
だから いくら知っていても
自分の知識が不完全であるということは知っておかないと
で 不完全であると思う
正しいではなくて あなた方の考え方よりはマシですよと言ってもいいんですよ
あなた方はそこら辺は勉強していないし
真面目にやってないんだから
私は真剣にやりましたから
あなた方のこの問題について
あなた方の考え方よりは私の考え方は間違っていると思いますよとと言ったっても
そんなこと言う必要はないんだけど
言う必要ないんだけど
言ったって別にどうったことはない
だからで正しいということを言っちゃったら
そこで間違い そこで問題が起こるんですね
お釈迦様が考えた まあ世界ではまあ自分の思想正しいという風に言わない方が
思わない方が 正しいと思って行動しない方が
まあ大変  優しい関係で何もぶつかることなく生きていられるんですね
しっかりと で 次に まあこれは一般的な思想体系
次のポイントっていうのは
このいろんなことを考えたっても
いろんな知識得たっても
何考えたっても不完全で自分知ってるデータが適当にもう組み合わせるだけのことで
それで人格 何て言いますか
人格を完成する方向にはいかないんですね
良い良い人間になるという問題は解決しません
勉強しても死な知ったんだからといって良い人間にはなりっこはないんです
人格完成はできません
人格完成するためには
お釈迦様がこのこういうことを考えなさいよと
3つぐらい決めてるんですね
だからそこら辺に知識がいる場合は人格完成に行くんですね
どうせ人間は知識で物事を考えるだったらそれを直さなくてはいけない
それはすごく大事なことなんです
人間の思考を直すということ
例えば正見というのは 1番目
正思惟 2番目でしょう
正見でいうのは 今日のお話からいうと
この師匠体系なんですよ
正見というのは 師匠体系
それで来たところで何を師匠するか
何を勉強するかっていうことは
内容は 2番目なんです
だから正見ではこのこの原因と結果というね
この原因でこの結果になるんだという姿勢体系
苦集滅道というのはインド側の話だから
で 果から因に行く 果から因に行く
それは普通ですよ 結果が何かあって
そこを調べたところで原因見つかるんだから
人が病気ですよ では病気は結果でしょうね
それで医者が原因を探す
だから果因の順番で正見説示しているんです
結果と結果があって それは先に見つかる
なぜこの結果になったかなんて
こんなことになったかと
その原因を探す そこで生命については
誰でも体験している 普通に味わっているものがドゥッカであって
なぜドゥッカが生まれるかという
この原因を探ってみること
それは正見なんですね
だからそれは師匠体系
それ そちらに目的も出ているんですね
例えば当たり前でしょうし
人が病気ですよとわかることはドゥッカであって
なぜこんな病気があるかということを発見することはドゥッカサムで苦集であって
それで終わりますかね
問題は 分かった あなたはこういうウイルスで病気になった
じゃあ帰ってくださいと
そう で問題解決しませんだから
次にその人の病気を治さなくちゃいけないんですね
そちらで健康的な状態になるんだという目的が成り立つでしょうに
そこで健康的な状態っていうのを説明すると
これからなるものではなくて
今ある状態をなくすことなんですよ
病院に行ったら いまだになかったすごい状態を作ってくるのではなくて
今ある問題の状態をなくしてくれる
それに健康だというだけ
だからドッカをなくすということが目的であって
特別に何かなるということは言わないんですね
それは論理的じゃないんです
まるっきりこの病気と医者の関係で理解した方がいいんです
だから言葉ではまあ健康を作ってくれるという風に言うんであって
特別に何かはい これ持って行ってくださいという風に何かもらうものじゃないんですね
外から健康というものを自分持っているものをなくすことなんですね
持っているものをなくした状態は健康状態なんですね
何を持っているかというと
病気を持っている それを消した状態に健康状態という
そういうことだから 生きる目的としては
仏教ではドッカを苦しみをなくす
で それに方法としては今の説明する方法が出ているんですね
ですから この その方法としても
やっぱりこれはもう人間の理解の問題だから
智慧のことだから まず思想体系を作って
それから何を考えるべきかと
正しく考えましょうと
というんですね それで正しく考えましょうというのはありえないんです
正しく考えることはできません
死ぬまで勉強したっても
もっと変なことを考える人と比べてかっこつけることできるだけ
それ別にどうしたことないんだからね
自分の考え方は正しいというために
変なことを考える人々でないと成り立たないんですよ
だから正しい思想というのは
正思惟というのはありえないんですよ
正思惟ありえないんだからこそ
お釈迦様はこの 3が正思惟ですよと
しっかりと決めているんです
その中 の 1番目は欲を離れた思惟と
こちらで日本訳なんですけど
ネッカンマサンカッ ネッカンマっていうのは
まあ単なるこの離れていく
捨てるっていう意味なんですよ
離れる 捨てるっていうぐらいの意味で考えてください
離れる方向へ考えてくださいと
捨てる方向へ考え方を持っていってくださいと
あればいいではないかではなくて
なければいいという方向へ思考しなくちゃいけないんですね
それだけですごく正しくなるんです
世の中の思考はあればいいという思考なんです
あればいいという思考が作った世界はドッカでしょ
人類が現れた日から今までも我々は考えてきたんですよ
いまだに考え方が完成していないんです
20世紀ですか 今は 21世紀になっても
考え方は完成してないんですよ
これからいろんなことを知ったりするでしょう
完成しない 完成したらどうなるんでしょうかね
完成するはずもないし
なんかまあ 仮に完成した状態考えたっても大変なことになるんですね
人にやること何一つなくなっちゃいますから
そこで次の世代で人類は破滅になる
例えば父親 両親たちの時代で
例えば知識が完成したならば
子供たちにやることないでしょうに
両親たちの時代で作った品物を使っちゃえばいいんです
でも自分には何か作ることはできない
で 次の世代には何もできなくて
もう原始時代に戻るっていうことになっちゃうんです
大変なことになるんです
ですから まあそれはもういつまでも完成するということはありえないんですからね
ですから お釈迦様が提示するのは
あればいいという思考の反対で
なければいいという方向も考えてみなさいよと
あればいいという思考が苦しみ作っちゃったんだから
なければいい そのなければいいという思考は
とことん考えてみると
やっぱり解脱っていうことを成り立つのですよ
それでないと 涅槃解脱の意味は成り立たないんですね
あればいいと思ったら
だからなぜ ただ簡単にね
まあ簡単に悟れるはずなんですけど
それほど難しいことでもないんだと思いますけど
なぜ悟りの心が生まれないかというと
この正思惟 なければいいという思惟さえももう完成していない
生まれていない それはいくらか生まれてくると
いくらか仏教の世界に励みたくなります
で それだけで成長が止まっちゃうんです
ですから なければいいという思惟が進むは進むほど
解脱の方向へも心進んでいくんですね
だから一番目 このネッカムサンカッパっていうのは
この欲を離れた思惟ということでもよろしいし
このやっぱり このなければいいというふうな言葉で理解した方がわかりやすいだろうと私は思います
これでわかりますという意味じゃないんです
うん で なぜなければいいという師匠がこの欲を離れる師匠だと書いてるんですかというと
まあこれはより分かりやすくするためなんですね
欲といえば この眼耳鼻舌身の刺激でしょう
体の刺激でしょう もう体に刺激与えてほしい
与えたいと思ったら まあいろんなものをなければ成り立たないでしょう
ですから あればいいという思想に行っちゃうんですよ
なければ良いではなくて
あればいいと そういう方向で我々はお金あればいいと
結婚できる相手がいればいいと
まあそれ単なる体に刺激が必要としてるだけなんですね
で それでどうなるかというと
今の世界なんですね すごい混乱の苦しみの世界もやりきれない世界
いくらやってもやりきれない世界が生まれてくる
結婚したいなと思ったら
思考はその方向へ行くでしょうに
思っただけで成り立ちませんだから
それはいろんなことをしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それでも大変なややこしい世界が自分が作っちゃうんですね
いくら作っても完全にはならないんですね
結婚しても その相手は完璧になるわけじゃないし
で いろいろことがそれからも生まれて生まれていく
ですから 欲から離れる思考を育てなさいというのはそういうわけなんですね
それはまあ そういう仏教専門用語を除いて喋るならば
なければいいという思考も思考してみた方が良いと思いますね
なぜなければいいということは思考できないかというと
それは欲絡んでるんだからね
時々人がいますよ あの結婚はしてるんだけど
子供がいなければいいと
すごい立派ですかね あれは立派じゃないんです
あれはただ欲だけなんですね
だからそういう単純な思考ではありません
子供がいたら二人の楽しみがなくなっちゃうんだと
自由が出てこないんだと
間に他の人々が入っちゃいますから
そういう欲があるんだから
まあ子供は子供がいなければいいと思ったりするだけなんですね
それは欲に基づいて考えることであって
そういう思考はなければいいという思考でもないんですね
だから 何かなければいいと思う人々はたまたまいるんじゃないかなと思うかもしれませんだけど
調べればそれは欲のためなんです
何かあればいいんだから
この邪魔者はなければいいって思うだけのことで
それも欲の思考なんですね
東京から離れて田舎で生活したいんだと
人がいないところで生活したいと
あるいは欲から離れた思考ではないんです
で 全て全部贅沢をやめて
何人か日本でもいるんだからね
この文化の世界からもう離れて
山でもう何かもう何か着て
そこら辺で自分で作って
何か食べてもう生活しているんですけども
あれはじゃあ欲から離れているお釈迦様の師匠ですか？というそれ師匠じゃないんですね
残念ですけど あれも結局欲の師匠なんですよ
ですから もっとちょっと難しいですね
それよりも単純じゃないんですね
まあとにかくなければいいという方向へ心を持てば持っていけば
もう思考を考えれば考えるほど
まあ解脱をする方向へ
仏道に励む方向へ気持ちがいくんですね
そうすると確実に人格がまあ完成していくんですね
で 2番目 まあこれ以上説明したって意味がないと思いますけど
アヴィャパーダサンカッパ
害意のない思惟ですね
アヴィャパーダっていうのは怒りのことで
で まあ壊したく 壊したくなる思考
攻撃したくなる思考 なんですよ
それもやめた方がいいと
壊したいと 攻撃したいと
ぶつかりたいと あの なければいいという思考が出てくると
大体それもまあ一応なくなっちゃいますけど
あの うーん まあとにかく人間の頭の中ですっごくこの壊して攻撃して戦って生きていきたいんですね
それもあればいいという思考で
自分が生きていきたいというね
まあ生きていきたい なぜ生きていきたくなっているんですかというと
分かってない それは単なる体の刺激なんですよ
体の刺激で喜んじゃって
それを誤解して生きていきたいと思っちゃうんですね
生きているということの意味さえも分かってないんです
ただ刺激欲しいだけ だから仏教で言えば刺激
刺激欲しいだけ まあ刺激欲しいだけっていうことは分かってない
その代わりに私は生きていきたいんだと変なことを言う
あれは変なアホなことなんですね
生きていきたいという
言ってる人に生きるということはについて質問してみてください
生きるということはどういうことですか？と
どういう機能 どういう働き
どういう内容ですか？と
わからないでしょうに
わからないのに生きていきたいと思っちゃう
ですから 生きるっていうことは
仏教の解釈では まあ刺激する
刺激欲しいというぐらいのことです
刺激で喜んじゃって 生きることに欲を作る
だから生きていきたい人が
自分が生きていきたいんだから
刺激欲しいんだから まあ欲しくない刺激をもう潰しちゃう
まあそういうことで 世界の中でいろんなもう有害的な思考っていうのはいっぱい出てきますね
だから一切の有害的な思考をやめると
だから有害的な思考をやめて無害なる
それよりも有害の反対の言葉なんですか？無害ではなくて
もっと欲しいという言葉ないんですか？有益
有益な言葉をことを考える
それも自分に対してこの欲的な有益ではなくて
やっぱり生命に対して有益なことを考えるということなんですね
この番目と番目もまとめて簡単に言えばこの慈悲の四 show なんですよ
慈悲の四 show をとことん育てなさいということなんです
この場合は二つに分けて
怒りは二つに 分けてるんですね
だから二番目は害意のない思惟であって
二番目は怒りのない思惟
三番目は害意のない思惟
だから怒りと害意のない思惟と
怒り自体が二つに分けただけ
だから考えてもいいんだけど
何考えてもいいんだけど
その考え方 考え自体が欲と怒りであってはならないということ
だから慈しみに基づいて思考すると
その問題は解決します
ふーむ これほんの僅かでもできればすっごく立派な人間になるんですけどね
この考え方がね 一向にもうほとんどもうもういくら私にいろいろ言いながら仏教勉強しているんだと言ったっても
もう微かにでも正思惟っていうのはね
できてくるんだったら
かなり立派な人間にはなります
だからその仏教そのものを勉強したっても
もうあればいいという思考に行っちゃうと
ごく普通の知識になって
いやらしい人間になるだけなんですよ
みんな世の中はね 勉強すればするほど
結局立派な大変素晴らしい人格のある人になるわけじゃなくて
我が強くていやらしい人間になるだけでしょうに
人の話は聞かないし わがままで
だいたい知識の世界そういう世界でしょう
勉強すればするほど 他の人々はすごくその人の怖ごわくて
もう尊敬して もう生活しなくちゃいけないし
もう大変大騒ぎな人格になるだけでしょう
ちょっとしたことで他人に怒鳴りつけるし
もういろんな問題作ったりするし
まあそれは欲の知識の思惟の場合でしょうし
たとえ仏教というものも同じ思惟パターンで勉強しちゃうと
まあ単なるいやらしい人間になるだけなんです
だからこちらで言ってるのはこの実践方法だから
真面目に真剣になければいいという方向と慈しみの方向へ思惟を回転させなくちゃいけない
思惟はストップにはならないんですよ
この瞑想で妄想 妄想と言うんだけど
それはストップにはならないんです
それは目があるんだから見えるでしょうに
たとえ完全たる悟り開いたっても目があるでしょうに
どうしますかね 見えるんですよ
お釈迦様は完全たる悟りを開いたところでも
刺激要らんだからということで目が見えなくなったとか
耳が聞こえなくなったとかね
わけじゃないでしょう
逆により見えるようになったとかね
より明確に聞こえるようになったとかね
よりものの味わいを味わえるようになったという結果になるだけのことですけど
だから この目耳鼻舌と同じく六番目の機能は考える機能でしょうし
ですから この思考の流れっていうのはストップにはならないんですよ
だからどうすればいいかというと
それはドゥッカを作る方向へ持っていかないで
まるっきり逆の方向へ
あればいいと思考 思惟からなければいい方向へ持っていく
なければいいという方向へ持っていけば
いきなり正反対でしょう
それでもないんですよ
仏教は中道だから 中道というのはこれとこれの真ん中ということでもないんですね
だからそちらに慈しみも入れてるんです
なければいい思考を考えなさいと言っちゃったら
もう黒の代わりに白いと言ったことと同じなんですね
甘さは嫌いだったら じゃあ苦味でいいでしょうか？と
これをそれはもうプラスマイナス思考で
それだけで正しい思考じゃない
思考はボックス童話っていうのはもう完璧に超越道で語ってるんですね
どんなポイント見ても
このブッダの超越道は見えるはずなんです
だから生死にしたっても
じゃあ間違ってる 死に死をやめてという
これ反対言ってるわけじゃなくて
超越道を言ってるんですね
そこで何考えるかって
なければいいということと
慈しみ だからないないということでもないんですよ
慈しみっていうのは何かあるという意味でもあるでしょうに
みんな幸せになってほしいと
喧嘩してほしくないと
全ての生命は楽しく明るく生きていればいいんじゃないかと
誰も損してはいけませんと
誰も誰かの誰かに損させて得をしてはいけませんと
そういう風に考えちゃうと
ある方向へちょっと偏るでしょうし
でも だってそれだけでも物足りないし
やっぱりものから離れた方が良いと
例えば 人間にとって全ての生命の幸せを考える人がいる
幸せ 全ての生命がどうすれば完璧な幸せになるでしょうかと
考えると どこかでぶつかっちゃうんですね
成り立たないんだと 例えば
一人の人が自分の希望通りに幸せに幸福になっちゃうと
また誰か誰かそれによって不幸になる
自分がもう体が弱いんだから
誰かにお世話してもらうと
あ それ幸せやと 大変親切に面倒見てくれてるんだからと
自分が幸せですけど 面倒を見てあげる人はどうですか？と
その人の生き方はどうなるんでしょうか？という問題が成り立っちゃうでしょうね
ですから この経済的な世界にしても
どんなことにしたっても
どこかで成り立たないということが出てくるでしょうね
幸せっていうものはね
もう完全には 一時的に一時的には成り立ちますけどね
若い人を見たら まあまあ
あんた結婚すればあんた楽しいでしょ？とか
じゃあいい相手見つかってくださいと
もう知ってる人は紹介してあげましょうというぐらいできますけど
それで完全になるということでもまだないしね
だから全ての生命もやっぱりこの取りたい取りたいという思考から離れて生きていきたいというその気持ちもちょっと離れて
て 脱出する方向へ行った方がいいという
自分だけではなくて 一切の生命も脱出した方がいいというところに
それしか答えがないと
という答えに行くはずなんです
で そういう思考にはやっぱりここまでということはあります
尚思義の場合は 何といいますか
終着駅があるんです あればいいという師匠には終着駅はありません
ヤマンテ線と同じ どんな駅に止まってみたっても
また次の駅があるんです
で 尚思義の場合は終着駅があります
終着点があります ですから
尚思義の人にはだけ 知ってるんだと
それ以上知るものはないんだと
ということは言えるんです
もっともっと知りたいと
もっと明確に考えたいという問題も解決する
その人にだけはっきりと白黒を決められます
白は白で 黒は黒いと それは尚思義の世界
ですから それをもう頑張ってみなきゃ
もう全然もう何なのかと
だからまあ 離れる思考と慈しみの思考で物事を考えてみることしか方法ないんですね
考えてみれば もう 終着
終点駅がある思考が出てきます
それは尚思義ですね まあ次にあるの三番目
カタマーチャ・ビッキャヴェー・サッマーワーチャー・ムサーワーダー・ヴェーラマニー・ピスナーヤ・ワーチャー・ヴェーラマニー・パルサーヤ・ワーチャーヤ・ヴェ
ーラマニー・サンパッピャラーパー・ヴェーラマニー・アヤング・ウッチャティ・ビッキャヴェー・サッマーワーチャー
正語 正語 正しい言葉 で
まあどうしても人間喋るんだからね
だから何喋ってもいいというわけじゃない
正しいものを喋らなくちゃいけない
それで正しいものっていうのは
私の日本語にははとがをっていうのはごちゃ混ぜ
もう何使ってるか自分で分かってないんですね
この場合ははですか？がですか？をですか？もうさっぱり
もうほとんどにはそれほど間違いませんだけど
あのミスはむちゃくちゃ
で だから私は正語でないと
そういう問題ではありません
例えばが使うべきところで
私はを使っても それは文法を間違っているんであって
私は正語を語ってないということではありません
ですから 正語っていうのは美しい言葉を語るということではありません
そういう風になっちゃうと
また習得終着点が駅がなくなっちゃいますよ
なぜならば より美しく語れる人もいるんだから
より完全な言葉で語る人がどうしても出てくる
言葉っていうのは相手を納得させることだから
例えばあるでしょうね
私が言っても聞いてくれないと
あんた言ってみたら 他の人言ってもよくあ
わかりましたと聞いてくれるとこあるでしょうに
だから説得力ある じゃあ彼のその人の説得力は完璧だと
そうじゃない 他の問題になったら
その人にも説得力なくなって
他の3番目の人が出て説得させなくちゃいけないんですから
だから言葉っていうのは説得力の問題ですけど
で それとこの怒り 快ち聞こえるかというぐらいのことなんですけど
そういう言葉が正語と仏教で見てないんです
なぜかというと 美しい言葉語るんだなと決めちゃったら
もう終着点がない世界にまた入り込んじゃう
ぐるぐる回る世界にまた入り込んじゃう
だから まあまあ できれば美しい言葉
ちゃんと文法的に正しく
しっかりした意味がある
曖昧でない言葉を語るというのは仏教では認められます
認めています いつでもできる
できるだけ言葉には説得力あってほしい
それから意味は曖昧であってはならないと
言いたい意味がはっきりして曖昧でない言葉で
その上誤解しないように言葉も選んで
文法的にも正しく語ると
その能力ある人はさらに文学的に
さらに美しい言葉 まあ語るならば悪くないんだけど
それで称号にはなりません
正しい言葉を語ったことにはなりませんね
ですから 執着点域がある言葉
称号なんですよ そこでこちらで言っているのは 4つでしょう
妄語から離れること いわゆる妄語を語らないこと
これ次の言葉 どのように読みますかね
両説  両説 それも語らないこと
これ悪  悪口  悪口から離れることも
悪口もしないこと 次は
記号  記号 この 4つに気を付ける
この 4つに気を付けると
必ずその執着点がある世界が成り立つんです
例えば妄語を語らないんだと決めてみたら
ものすごく楽になります
もうまあまあ 別にどうってことないの
嘘をついたってもと思ったら
いくらでも語れるでしょ
妄語だから ないものだから
いくらでも考えて考えて語れる
あの いろんなこの子供たちの世界に例を出しますけど
このポケモンのストーリーなんていくらでもモンスターが作るんですよ
もう何種類いるかわからない
で 子供たちも競い競い合って
もう全部の名前を覚えてるんだとか
もうもうもう競い合っているんだけど
かわいそうなんですよ
あれは もしもうあれはもう剛という
まあもう剛という いわゆるないものだからね
で いくらでも考え出せるでしょうに
どんな どんな言葉の最後にも「もん」入れちゃえばね
まあこの子供たちその何々「もん」
それでモンスターができるんですよ
昔は「マン」でしたけどね
今は「もん」になっています
昔はバイキンマンとかアンパンマンになっていたんだけど
今は「マン」は「もん」になっている
じゃあ「マン」の世界終わったんですかというと
終わったわけじゃなくて
もう飽きちゃっただけなんです
だからもうサンドウィッチマンもいくらでも作られますでしょう
もうペストリーの世界から見れば
もうペストリーの名前っていくらあるかわかりませんだからね
もうサンドウィッチマンとパニニーマン使い
それ同じものなんです
サンドウィッチ パニニというのは
ただ イタリア語を使っているか
英語を使っているかというぐらいな
それでもつ作れるでしょうに
ですから終わりがないんですね
とにかく 「マン」の世界終わって
現代の子供たちはたちが「もん」の世界に入ったってわけじゃないんです
子供たちの師匠がどれぐらい発展しているかと
そんなの全然関係ない
アンパンマンで遊んで成長した子供はあまり知識が足らなくて
ポケットモンで遊んでいる子供の方が頭がいいってこともまるっきりないでしょ
ただ何かで遊んでいるだけ
だから成長はない 人格成長もない
そこで妄語っていうのは語ろうと思ったらキリがない
それでその中で差が生まれてくる
差別が生まれてくる あの人は私よりも喋られるんだと
悔しいと 私より立派に嘘を言えるんだと
例えばこの小説やらね
昔だったらね アラビアン物語とかね
色々あったでしょうね
全て妄語でしょ だからアラビアン物語のようなものはいくらでも書けるでしょうに
いくらでも書ける だから当時の世界でアラビアン物語でしたけど
今の世界では あの 何と言いますか SF
でしょう いろんなUFOが来るは
宇宙船があるは もういろんなもう宇宙船
異星人たちがね 出てくるわとかね
それでまたアラビアン物語と同じく
いろんな能力を持っていると
同じなんですね だから発展ないんです
今 今 今の人々を遊んでいるSF映画の中でもね
何も発展ない 昔は獣隊に乗ってあちこち行った
行ったと行っただけで
今のSF映画の場合は
まあいきなり移動する
能力ある異星人がいる
同じことでしょうに だから妄語になったらもうキリがない
大変苦しみの世界 だからやめてみなさいと
あるものだけ語ってみなさい
そうすると終わりがあるでしょうに
はい 終わりと 事実だけ語る人にとってはあのストレスがないんですよ
終わります だから正語っていうのは妄語を語らないこと
事実以外のことは語らないというぐらいのことで決めちゃえば
もうかなり楽になる 執着点がある人生になります
執着域があるということは完全ということなんですよ
次の言葉っていうのは両説なんですけど
二枚舌  二枚舌 で で 二枚舌でしたってのは日本語の意味と仏教の意味はどこまで似ているかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの この平和を壊す言葉なんですね
仲間割れをする言葉 するのやめなさいと
[笑い]色々解釈できますけどね
人の悪口言うな 悪口と言ったっても
もう噂ですけどね 噂の場合は決まって言って
人の悪いところを言う
悪いところ言って 結果としては仲間割れなんですね
人々を仲良くすることをなくすということなんですね
それは仏教で言ったらやってはいけないことだと
人は仲良くするように話しなさいと
平和をもたらせるように話しなさいと
すごい喧嘩している二人についてしゃべって
とにかくあの喧嘩の炎がどんどんどんどん少なくなるように喋りなさいということでもあるし
だからといって妄言を喋っちゃうとキリがなくなっちゃうし
妄言になって仲が良くなったっても
妄言だとバレたところでまた喧嘩するでしょうし
だから人間同士でこのいつでも仲良くしてほしいということはものすごい徹底しているんですね
なぜそこまで徹底しているかというと
この人間はみんなもう違うんだと
同じじゃないんだということを仏教はよく知っているんですよ
一人一人別な個人だから
別なものを考えたり 別な好き嫌いがあったりするのは
それは問題にしちゃうと生きていられないでしょうに
それを認めなさいよと
ご飯好きな人はパン好きな人もいるんだと認めなさいよと
我々認めないんですね
だから差別感が生まれるんですよ
だからありとあらゆる戦いが生まれてくるので
それは無知なんですね
皮膚の色が黒い人を見て
黄色い人を見て 白い人を見て
もう茶色の人いろいろいるんですよ
しょうがないでしょうに
なんでそれ認めないんですかね
どれぐらいそれアホらしいかと
皮膚の色黒いだからもう認めませんと
バスに乗ってはいけないんだと
学校に行ってはいけないんだと
そういう世界でしょうし
それはまあ黒人差別してる人々だけではなくて
みんなやってるんです
どんな人間も 相手の差は認めない
だからその知恵が必要なんですね
違いますよと 自分の子供であっても上の子と下の子は違うんだと
兄弟はなぜ喧嘩するかというと
相手の差は認めない 自分の価値観にならなくちゃいけないんだと思ったりする
そこはまるっきり バカバカらしい
わかりやすくしたければ
もう南アフリカで皮膚が黒いんだから学校に行ってはいけませんと
どうしても勉強したければそこら辺にハットなんか作って
そこら辺に何かを教えてあげる
それだけ 大学なんか入ったらいけませんとずっとやっていたんだから
バスはあるんだけど 乗ってはいけません
色が違いますから アメリカでもありましたけど
あんたがどうしてもバスに乗るだければ
何かボロボロバスあって
それは黒人用 それはずっと最近まで平気で認めてたでしょうに
ですから それおかしいでしょ
日本のいじめって何ですかね
例えばハーフにしたっても
アメリカのハーフだったらそれももう人気者でアイドルですけどね
もし黒人のハーフだったらどうですかね
最悪でしょうね そういうことである人が私にも日本はあなたにいいですね
もうこの国で差別ないんだからと一回言われて
あのもう小田急線に乗ったところで
その人が降りるところまでもうとことん止まることなく喋った
もう二度と外人見たらもう逃げようと思うところぐらいに
ひとかけらも自分のプライドというもの
人間としてのね 残さないようにと壊しちゃったんです
人間じゃないっていうところまで
そんな言葉では言わない
違ういろんな情報を出しながら
言葉で人間じゃないよ
その彼が怒ってかかってくるだけでしょう
そうじゃなくて そうですね
まあそれもまあそうでもないと思いますけどね
いろいろ考えちゃうと
私はこういうことも差別ではないかなと思います
こういうこともありますけど
これも差別ではないかなと思いますけどとか
比べて比べて比べて とことんとことん言っちゃうと
もう人の人格も壊れていくんです
だからいけないことは言ってはいけません
とにかく  ですから 私のポイントは差別的じゃないんです
私は言いたい 私の個人的な立場っていうのは
これはもうありえないことで
人間っていうのは自分が正しいと
相手は認めないという立場はみんなにあるはずなんです
日本人にだけないということはありえないんだと
なぜならば お釈迦様が科学的な真理を語ったんだから
そんないい加減な妄想概念は良くないんです
それは智慧の世界で 智慧が生まれてこない限りは
心にあるのは差別なんですよ
だから私はそういう立場で喋ってるんだから
いくらでも喋られますけど
だから本当に個人個人が違います
全ての生命は いろんなところで違うんです
似ているのはないんです
それ嫌と言ったら生きていられますかね
似てないんだから嫌ですよと言ったら生きていられませんよ
誰一人この存在の中で自分に似ているものはいないんだから
だから生きる道っていうのは仲良くすること
仲良くするということは
認めること 相手の生き方
相手の好き嫌い それは他の人に邪魔だったらね
ちょっと気をつけなさいよというのは
それは別なこと 話で まあとにかく相手に
他人に邪魔になるのも
他人の差を認めない時だけなんですよ
認めるともう邪魔にならないんだからね
私たちは他の人のことを嫌いになったり
嫌になったり あの人々と一緒にやりたくないと思ったりする瞬間で
心に出てくるのは相手の差を認めてないということなんです
認めたったら別に何の問題もないんです
だから喋る時もその立場でお釈迦様は二枚舌は良くないんだと
二枚舌になっちゃったらいくらでも喋られます
差はいくらでももう当たり前
いくらでもあるんだから
違うところは だから人と人が仲良くしないことで喜びを感じちゃうと
その人には完全に喜び感じられますかね？どれぐらい人間壊すことできますかね
人間の調和を だから自分知ってる何人かの仲の間の関係を壊すだけで
それで他の人とすごい仲良くしているとまた悔しくなるでしょうに
またそれも壊したくなる
でもできないでしょう
だからキリがないんですよ
だから二枚舌も終着点がない言葉で
ですから喋るならば仲良くするように
仲良くできるような言葉を喋ってください
で 仲良くするように喋る場合は
まあ一応終着点がまた出てくるんですね
言葉に で 番目の悪口っていうのは
この人の相手の気持ちを嫌な気持ちにすることなんですね
相手を嫌な気持ちにする言葉
で 番目はこの奇語という無駄話
無駄話っていうのは何か目的がない
意味のない言葉ですね
ですから 別にこのポケモンのストーリーでも何でも作ってもいいんだけど
その中から何か学ぶものあるならば
無駄話にはならないんですね
何もない場合は まあ意味がないんですね
そこで無駄話しようと思ったら
またいくらでも喋られるし
キリがないし そういうことで言葉気をつけるということ
正語っていうのはそれが正語であって
言語学的に正しい言葉を喋ることではないんです
よく喋っている言葉には妄語でない意味がある
で 人が仲良くするという
それからあまり気持ち悪くならないようにと
で それ終わったところで
カタモーチャ ビッキャウェー サッマー カッマン トーパーナアティパータ ウェーラマネー アディンナーダーナ ウェーラマネー
カーメスミッチャーチャーラーヴェーラマニアングッチャティビッキャレーサンマカンマントー
で あの 章五ですね 正しい行い
行為 で 正しい行いって何なのかと
正しい行為っていうのは何なのかと
その場合は お釈迦様はちょっと違う
ほんのちょっと違うことな立場なんですね
言葉と違って で 行為っていうのはそんなたくさん人間にできるわけじゃないんですよ
体でやってるものだからね
できることは一応決まってるんですよ
言葉と違います 言葉にはキリがなく喋れますけど
体はキリがなく動かすっていうことはできないんです
体は弱いんだから まあすぐ疲れる
走るんだと思ったっても
時間も必死な勢いで走れるかというと
それは走れません 重いものをもう運ぶんだと思ったっても
いくらでもできるわけじゃないんですね
ですから 体の行動の場合はね
まあ一応自分の体力はこれぐらいだっていうことはもうはっきり決まってるんです
まあ欲としてはもっと体力あってほしいと欲があるんだけど
やっぱりそれでもみんな知ってますよ
これはもうキリがありますと
これ以上できないんだというね
ってことを知ってます
ですから まあ一応もう限りがある行為なんですね
人間の行為っていうのは
その中でどこに気をつけるかと
それでも殺生 生命を殺すことを気をつける
それだけはやらない それから他人のものを盗むこと
自分のもので以外なものはもう取らないこと
だが 何か必要であるならば
それは自分で儲かるかもらうかどちらかなんですよ
取ってはいけません それから
欲しない行為をしないこと
体に刺激を与えてもいいんだけど
それだけに刺激を与えればいいんだからといって遊んではいけませんと
で そういうことで自分の体の生き方が壊れてしまいますね
生きていられなくなっちゃいますね
まあ思いつっても遊ぶぞと思って遊んじゃったらもうすぐ死んじゃうんですね
結局生きていられなくなっちゃいますね
いろんな病気になったり
大変なことになって 結局はもう長生きはできない
殺生する人にも決して長生きはできない
自分の命もなくなってしまっちゃうんです
物を取る人にも結局平和にできることはできなくなっちゃう
もうはっきりしてますよ
嘘をついたり 賄賂を取ったり
泥棒したりしちゃうと
それで もう自分の人生終わっちゃいますから
だから 体の行為っていうのは知られたもんで
大したことできないんだから
それは死ぬまでいろいろ行為できるように
その三つを気をつけなさいという
しない こういう三つを
それはサンマ カンマンと
次に あの 何でしょうかね
ショウミョ
カテモーチェビッキャレーサンマアジーボイデビッキャレーアリエサワコミッチャーアジーバンパハヤサンマアジーレーヌジービカンカッフェーティアヤンウッチャティビッキャレーサンマアジーボ
で こちらでは説明はあまり入ってないんだから
他の経典では説明入ってますけど
正命っていうのはこの仕事のこと
嫌な もう何でもして生活するんじゃなくて
いいことをして生活する
正しいことをしてご飯食べればいいんですよ
金儲かりたいんだからって
どんな手段もいいわけじゃないんです
やってはいけないことも世の中にあります
やってはいけない仕事もものたくさんあります
お金がたくさんあった方がいいと思ったっても
だからって銀行強盗するして金持ちになるんだっていうことはよくないし
いい権力ある仕事を見つけたんだから
とにかく取りたい放題
人々からお金取りましょうと
それですぐもう金持ちになるんだって
そういうことはもう正しい生き方ではないんですね
ですから 自分の仕事っていうのは
まあプライドを持って
まああまり収入がなくても
ちゃんといい仕事をして生活しているんだというところなんですね
だから正業というのは大体それぐらいのことで
詳しく説明しているところでは
この妄号していくってはいけない
あの 何といいますか 見舞いした
それも仕事になる場合
あるでしょうに 無駄話をして仕事にする
それで食べられるとかね
そういうことはしてはいけない
殺生して食べてる人々もいますね
人殺すこと 生命殺すことを自分の職業だと
そういうのはもうみっともない生き方だから
そういうことをやっちゃいけない
泥棒して生活する人もいるし
よこしまない行為で生計を立てている人々もいるしね
そういう仕事もやめなさいということで
他のところで武器やらね
毒やらね まあそういうものは作ってはいけませんし
売ってはいけませんと
それから生き物を売ってはいけませんと
そういうのは商売の場合は仏教ではね
麻薬 酒作ってはいけません
売っては商売もいけません
それから武器といろんな生命殺す道具作ってもいけませんし
商売でもいけません 私は売ってるだけですよっていうのもいけませんと
仏教徒だったらやめた方がいいと
生き物売ってはいけません
商売にしてはいけませんと
権利ないんですよ 生き物は生き物だから
だから泥棒になっちゃうんですよ
例えば私があちこち鳥を捕まってきて
ここで可愛いペットになりますよと言って売ったりするでしょうね
ペットのその動物のその鳥の権利は
野生で生まれて生まれた鳥には野生で自由に生活する権利があるでしょうに
アフリカとオーストラリアのトカゲトカゲさんたちには
そこら辺の環境で楽しく生きる権利あるでしょうに
それでトカゲを捕まって日本に輸入して
もう 100万円で売るとか
珍しいトカゲだからといって
そういうのはよくないと
それぐらい厳密に生きなくちゃいけないんですよ
生活っていうのは厳密であれば厳密に
それはこの小さな生命にも生きる権利があるんだという
捕まる自由 権利がないんですよ
だから西洋思想とはもう反対ですよ
汚い西洋思想と比べて
ペットぐらい商売は何のこともないんだとかね
酒屋さんは何のこともないんだと言ったっても
全然我々には通じません
なんで最初からもう腐ってる考え
考え方の一部取る必要ありますかと
それで決していいことになったわけじゃないでしょうね
世の中で悪いことをする人ってのは
みんな酒に必ず酒飲むでしょうね
人殺してから酒一杯飲むではなくて
人を殺す前に酒飲むでしょうね
相手と喧嘩してから一杯飲みましょうということじゃなくて
飲んでから喧嘩するでしょうね
悪いことする前に必ず手が行くのはもう酒でしょうし
で 麻薬も同じことでしょうし
だからもう大変世の中でこの
このテロリストたちなんかはね
もう収入資源はもう麻薬でしょ
だからそういうものはまあ
ペットの商売までも仏教はまあやらない方がいい
ペットはまあ本当は要りませんしね
本当に自由に心優しく人仲良く生きる方法を分かっている人にとっては
別に寂しいとかなんとか
誰か自分の奴隷にしなきゃあかんというわがまま出てこないんですよ
で 成り立てない 要らなくなるんです
だから動物にしたっても
まあ人間の助けを必要だなと思ったら
優しい人のところに動物が勝手に行くでしょうし
だからいろいろ探検してみてください
いろんなお寺にしてみたって
もうこの山のお寺にしても
結構もう野生の動物でももうすげー勝手に来てご飯もらったりして
で もう勝手に遊んだりしてまた帰ったりすると
じゃあ捕まってペットにしてやろうとは思わないんです
まあハトは人間にも慣れてますけどね
他のカラスにしたっても
本当に親切にちょっとちょっともう来て餌欲しいなと思ったところであげちゃうと仲良くしますよ
人間と ですから まあそんなこのペット概念っていうのもものすごいこの恐ろしい概念で
自分が幸せであればいいやと
だから他の人と仲良くしたくない
人間関係でトラブったりする
混乱したりする ストレス溜まったりする
その思考が間違ってるでしょうに
思考でぶつかってるでしょうに
だから相手の差を認めない
他の人と違いますよと
だから仲良くできない
それで誰かの自由を奪って自分のペットにするだけで
それ自体が恐ろしいことなんです
そういうことだから はっきりした論理で動物の売買も仏教徒の仕事としては禁止しているんです
だからそうやってこのけしからんなみっともない生き方
仕事で食ってはいけませんと
どうせ人間っていうのは誰でも何か仕事をして生活しなくちゃいけないですから
まあ人の役に立つことをしてしてあげて
その収入で生活すればいいんです
それは正命 次は何なのか
正精進 katamo ca bhikkhave sammavayama idhbhikkhave b
hikkhu anuppannana papakana
akusalana dhammana anuppada candajane ti vayamati
viriya arabhati chittam paggannati
padahati uppannana papakana akusalana dhammana pahana cand
ajane ti vayamativiriya
arabhati chittam paggannati padahati anuppannana k
usalan dhammana uppada candajane
ti vayamativiriya arabhati chittam paggannati pa
dahati uppannana kusalan dhammana
titthiyasammosaya bhayo bhava vepullaya bhavana pari
puriya candajane ti vayamativiriya
arabhati chittam paggannati padahatiayam uccati bhikkhave sammavayama
で sammavayama
っていうのは正精進 努力しましょうと
努力しましょうと言ったって
またキリがなくて ものすごくもなく
大雑把でね 意味が結局掴めない
もう言葉が浮いてる言葉なんですね
努力しなさいと だから執着点があるところに努力ということをこちらでも
何に努力するかというと
心にある悪いところ 自分の性格にある悪いところをなくそうなくそうと努力する
頑張る 今までやったことがない悪いことはこれからも絶対やらんそうとずっと努力する
それから自分の心にあるいいところをとことん成長する
するそうと 性格でしょう
とことん成長して完成するんだと
今までやったことがない
いいこともやってみるんだと
その努力なんですね 努力っていうのは
だから意味がある 浮いてないんです
頑張りましょうというふうな感じで
頑張りましょうという単なる言葉で浮いてますよ
何かに何か付け加える
勉強を頑張ってくださいと
仕事を頑張ってくださいという何か言わないと
浮いてますよ ですから
こちらでは人格を完成に努力しなさい
良い立派な人間になるために努力しなさいということで
言葉はちゃんと浮かない
浮いて浮いてこないようにしているんですね
だから これこそ人間の精進の目的なので
これは執着点がある目的なんですよ
精進なんですよ 他の金儲かるために頑張るんだとか
美しくなるために頑張るんだとかね
そういうのはもうキリがないんですから
執着点がなくなっちゃって
苦しみが生まれてくる
こういうことに努力すると
ちゃんと執着点があって
いつでも喜びを感じる
昨日より今日は自分が立派な人間だということで喜びを感じることができます
で 次にサンマーサティ
イダ
・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・カーエー・カーヤーヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ・アターピ・サンパジャノー・サティ・マーヴィーナイーヤ・ローケー・アビッジャー
・ドーマナッサン・ヴェーダーナー・スー・ヴェーダーナー・ヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ・アターピ・サンパジャンという
また四念処経の基本の柱が出てくるんですね
だから実践する場合は体のことに気づく
体の感覚に気づく 心の回転に気づく
それからいろいろ心理に現象に対して気づいて発見して見る
心の働きですね それは智慧を開発するためにどうしても必要な条件なんですね
で 8番目はサンマーサマーディ
カタ
モーチャ・ビッケーヴェー・サンマー・サマーディ・イダ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・ヴィヴィッチャー・ロカーミー・ヴィヴィッチャ・グセレーヒ・ダンメーヒ・
サヴィタックアン・サヴィチャーラン・ヴィヴェーカジャン・ピーティ・スカン・パタマッジャーナン・ウパサンパッジャ・ヴィーラティ
正定ですか 正精進とすり替えてくるのは
48ページですから また比丘たちよ
清浄とは何かと そこでサマーディですね
心落ち着いた状態 混乱していない状態というのは大変いいことで
大変喜びを感じることです
それをこちらでは四つの段階に分けて順番に書いています
最初に心は喜んでくる場合は
この欲から心が離れるとすぐ落ち着く
欲を追っていくと切りがないんだから
もうどこまで行けばいいかということがなくなっちゃいますからね
海のど真ん中にいるような感じなんですね
そこでほんのちょっとでも島なんか見たら落ち着くんですね
そこまで泳げばいいんだと
だからその心欲から離れるだけで心が落ち着いてくるんです
サヴィタック サヴィチャーラン最初はまあいろんなことを考えてはいるんだけど
やっぱり欲からは離れている
普通の心の状態っていうのは
このもう海のもう全くもう太平洋の真ん中でもいいんだけど
そこら辺に人がまあ起こっちゃったような感じなんですよ
どこへ泳げばいいかっていうのはやっぱりわからない
だからすごい混乱する
結局は泳げなくなっちゃうんですね
同じところにいるんですよ
精進もできなくなっちゃう
だから欲が心にある人は成長しない
遊びたい 美しいものを見たい
美味しいものを食べたいとかね
欲を追っている人にとっては
もう海の真ん中で遭難した人と同じなの
遭難というのはその場合は
で そういう人と同じく
どこを泳いでいた方がいいかわからないんですね
で そこでそこら辺で島が見えちゃったら
見えただけですけど まだ恐ろしい海の真ん中にいるんですよ
それでも心が落ち着くんですよ
目的が出てくるんです
精進できるんです やっぱりちょっと遠いんだけど
そこら辺まで泳ごうと力絞って進むんですね
だから欲から離れた瞬間から心が成長する
そこまでは成長しない
一箇所にいるんです ですから
この人間のこの欲世界のこの発展というものは
心の成長ではありません
ただ 土を持ってくるだけ
六十階の建物を作ったというのは
土で鉄やら持ってきて積み重ねただけなんです
心の成長ではありません
だから科学発展や色んなことというのは
単なるこの地球の土をあっちにあるものをこっちに持って
こっちにいるものをこうやって売れ返したりするとかね
そういうことをすることのだけで心の成長がないんです
なぜかというと 欲に溺れているんだからなんです
欲という海の中に溺れているんですね
だから進歩はない だから欲から離れた瞬間で目的見える
だから島が見えた瞬間で海から離れようということが出てくる
だからこの第一禅定っていうのは
大体島が見えたっていうぐらいのことなんです
欲から心が離れた でもヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラあります
思考があります 欲の中にいる時の我々
一生懸命考えているでしょうに
明日何食べればいいんですか？とか
あの人どういう風にいじめればいいんですか？とか
いろんなことを考えているんだから
でも欲の思考だから落ち着きのない
島が見えた途端 それでも考えてはいるんだけど
泳いではいるんだけど
やっぱり落ち着いて よし
頑張るぞということになってくるんですね
その時の感じる喜び 海に流されていた人が島見えた瞬間でどんな喜びを感じるかと
第一禅定を発見する人がそれぐらいの喜びを感じるんです
第二禅定っていうのは
一応ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラがない
妄想はない いわゆる島のたとえで言えば
もう島になんとか近寄って
いわゆる浅い海のところに行ったということなんです
もう泳がなくてもいいんです
立てますから だから心にヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラいりません
瞑想には第二禅定では思考もいりませんし
もう立てるぐらいのところに
あるいはもう階段 海岸の方にも近寄ってきたんだという
第三禅定ではピーティヤーチェ・ヴィラーガ・ウペッカー・コーチェ・ヴィーハヤティ
サトーチェ・サンパジャノー・スカーンチェ・カーエーナ・パティサン・ヴェーデーティ
これ読んだ いい そうですね
そこでこの第三禅定の場合は
この激しい喜びはなくなって落ち着くんだと
楽になるんだ 例えば一応島に上ると
島に上ったらもう大変楽でしょうに
楽しいでしょうね 疲れているでしょうね
それで横になって もう今までの疲れがそこで出てくるんだからね
何のことなく寝られると
で それを第三禅定ぐらいな状態で
第四禅定っていうのはウペッカーのサマディなんですね
あーよかった あー助かりました
あー命拾いしましたという気持ちも消えちゃうんですよ
例えば島でまあ 2日目にもなりましたというと
まあ命拾いしました そういうことがなくて
何か食べ物あったらそれを食べて
まあ生活をするというふうな第四禅定なんですね
そうやって心の落ち着きにも段階があります
すごく落ち着きが得られる
それも作ってみなさいよと
そこの間では 煩悩をなくす方法はこの 8種類の八正道なんですね
だから本当は八正道っていうのは仏教の道すべてなんです
それ以外悟る方法っていうのはないんです
それはもう一人一人にとってもかなりかなりのもんなんですけど
やってみれば必ずしも悟りには至る方法なんです
真理見つかるんです 正見さえあればサンマーサティやる
サティやると念を実践すると確実に真理は見えてきます
で それは他の経典でいろんな方法で増やして増やして説明しています
例えば経典と同じ もっと大きいんでしょうね
戒律の本というのは すごい膨大な戒律ある
戒律の生き方のことでしょ
ですから正語 正語と正業なんですよ
その 3つなんですね この膨大な戒律
テキストに書いているのは
いろんな経典でもいろんな分析がありますけど
全て八正道の中に入るんです
そこでヴィパッサナーのサティパッターナ瞑想する人が
その八正道の方にも心を持っていって理解していくんですね
で 最終的にはまあ物事は生まれてくるんだということを
消えていくんだということにサティを持っていく
で 体を観察して それからじわじわと感覚を観察して
それも上手にできたところで心の変化を観察していって
それも上手にできたところで真理に
法を観察するようにすると
心理の方に観察すると
それも自分の心 自分の中
外の両方という三段階
三観察する そうすると現象っていうのは生まれて消えていくんだっていうことが見えてくる
それは悟りの心 尊じに悟りの心が生まれてきます
そのサティパッターナ
この四つの智慧 四つの念ですか
四種類の念をサッタヴァッサーニ
エワン・バーベ サッタヴァッサーニ
今説明する ずっとこの行典説明した通りに七年間修行するならば
ディンナアナン・パラアナン・アンニャタラン・パラン・パーティーカンカ
二つの結果から一つ得られるんだと
ディッティエヴァ・ダンメ・アンニャ
すぐ悟れる サティはウパード・セーセー・アナーガーミタ
もし完全に悟ることができなかったならば
二度とこの世に戻ることはないんだと
他のどこかに生まれ変わりますけど
そこで悟れるんだと もう完全できなかったらもう一回試験受けなくちゃいけないんだからね
だから完全に合格して解脱するか
あるいはあと一回になるかという
で お釈迦様すぐにティッタンとビッティエ・サッタヴァッサーニ
もう七年はいいんですよ
もう チャッ バーベ・チャヴァッサーニ
六年間やっても 六年間やってみてくださいと
それでまた それは文学的な言葉の使い方なんですね
たった七年ですよと いや
六年でできますよと いや
五年修行すればできますよと
また いえ 四年やってみなさいと
悟れますよと また 三年やってみなさいと
三年も長すぎやと 二年やってみなさい
悟れますよと そこで 二年長すぎですね
まあ一年頑張ってみなさいと
他の人々っていうのは
いろんなことに我々は何十年も頑張るでしょう
一年頑張ってみなさいよと
一年長いというならば
サッタ・マーサーニ 七ヶ月間ぐらいでも修行に励んでみなさいと
あるいは五ヶ月間 四ヶ月間
三ヶ月間 二ヶ月間 頑張ってみなさいと
一ヶ月間に減るんです
そこにティッタンとビッティエ・アッデマーソ
お釈迦様最後に一ヶ月間修行しなくていいんで
二週間かけてやってみなさい
もう悟られてます それで
それも減るんですよ 一週間真剣にやってみなさい
この修行方法 悟れるんだと
悟れなかったら もう二度とこの輪廻に戻れない境地に行くんだと
不還果という境地に行くんだと
七週間 七日間よりは縮んでないんです
一週間ですね 縮むんだったら一秒間まで縮むといういい加減なことでもないんです
一週間で止まってるんです
だから お釈迦様一週間という言葉を言いたいんですよ
いかに強力で いかに直接的で
いかに科学的だということを強調したいんですよ
あんた方はくだらんことに
苦しみ作ることに一生かかってるでしょうにと
苦しみ脱するために一週間かけてみたらどうですかと
すごい大胆におっしゃってるところなんです
たった一週間休み取れないかと
だからバカなことを言うなよと
みんな言うのは時間がない
暇がない 一週間時間取れないかと
だから逃げられません
だからお釈迦様は完全に衆生の救済の道をおっしゃっているんです
完全に一切衆生の解脱の方法をおっしゃっている
だから あの人こういうわけでできないんだとかね
だから一週間修行に行ったっても
家のことやら くだらんことやら
新聞のことやら いろんな頭は欲から思考が悪いんだから
正思惟やってないんだから
もうできないんです だから八正道はやってないんだからできないんだ
ちゃんと真面目にやってみれば
みるみるうちに成長するんです
一日 二日 三日で  [背景音]だからそれぐらい確実
確固たることだから エーカーノアヤンビッケ
これは一方通行の道やと
すべての苦しみをなくすために
一方通行の道という この経典の初めにや
初めに出てきた文句で
最後にきれいに終われちゃうんですね
苦しみをなくすために
道を体験するために 涅槃を体験するために
これこれはもう一番一方通行の直行
直行便 直行便だよと そこでまた誰かが他の宗派の人々でも
経典なんかに何か自分の主観なんか入れられると困るんだから
だから経典はもう編集できないように鍵かけるんですよ
だから初めはエーカーノアヤンビッケで
これは直行 直接な一方通行道ですよということでタイトル付けて始めて
最後に故にこのこれ道ですよで言って終わっちゃうんです
それでもう何も指さす
何か入れることはできなくなっちゃうんです
それで終わらないんですよ
イダマウーチャバガワ
お釈迦様このように説明しましたと
それもピリオド 鍵 イダマウーチャバガワ
これはお釈迦様はおっしゃいましたというのが終わりなんですね
もう一つピリオドかけるんですよ
アッタマナアテビクバクトバスタンアビナンドゥンディと
それ聞いて比丘たちが大変喜びました
それも終わりという意味なんです
経典が終わった もうここで終わり終わり終わり終わり終わりと
そうやってこの経典を変化しないように
いい加減な人々はまた言葉一つ入れ込んじゃって
また一つ入れ込んじゃったりする
できないように厳密にこの何て言いますか
ガードするんです まあこちらはまあ三つのガードなんですけど
それでまあ後でこの編集とか
この欠如で まあそれから書き写したりする場合はもう一つのガードを入れるんですよ
それはマハーサティパッタンスッタニッティタンナワマン
マハーサティパッ第一念処経はニッティタン終わりました
これは9番目ですよと
そうするとテキストのテキストの間にも言葉新しい経典を差し込む差し入れできません 9
番目だから番号振ってるんだから
そういうわけでパーリ経典っていうのは純粋に守られちゃったんです
編集できないように 厳密にもうお釈迦様の言葉を真ん中に入れて
上と下でいろいろガードをつけておくんです
だから 現代学者が例えばサティパッタースッタニッティタンと書いているんだから
それは決してお釈迦様が言ったわけじゃないんだと
ナワマンての順番はどうせお釈迦様が言うわけじゃないんだから
これは後で書いたんだから
これは後の経典やと決めるんです
そういうもう学問研究っていうのは
そんなレベルでやってるんです
でも我々にとってはそんなガキみたいな話ではね
ちゃんと真ん中に純粋にこの真水が残っている
これで話を終了します